I think things can get you learned on  YouTube I think what you pay for is  speed you pay for troubleshooting you  pay for somebody else who's already done  it and not [ __ ] up as many times as  you're about to I've paid for tons of  one-on-one stuff I knew enough to get  ads going I wasn't like a genie at it I  just knew enough to get lead so I could  sell I wanted to get more sophisticated  I paid a guy who had a course he said I  only do courses I don't sell my time and  I was like it's America everyone sells  their time just tell me what the price  is went back and forth and finally it  was like 750 an hour and I was like done  and I think I did eight sessions with  them so it cost me like 5 600 bucks  because I didn't want to just learn how  to run ads I want to learn how he would  think through running my ads